[Música]
y llegamos para hablar de salud de aquí
en directo américa ya está conmigo en el
estudio más romeros a la mar vamos a
hablar de las posibles causas de la
esclerosis múltiple volvemos a tocar
este tema en nuestra sección de salud
aquí en nuestro programa un estudio
reciente concluyó que esta enfermedad la
provoca un virus muy común de que
estamos hablando más del virus
epstein-barr puede sonar como un nombre
muy extraño pero en realidad seguro has
oído hablar de él porque es el virus que
también provoca la mononucleosis y que
infecta alrededor de un 95 por ciento de
la población mundial a lo largo de su
vida ahora se sabe que puede estar en la
raíz de esta esclerosis múltiple una
enfermedad autoinmune donde el cuerpo
ataca las neuronas tanto del cerebro
como de la médula espinal el estudio se
publicó en science en la revista science
con 10 millones de con los datos de 10
millones de personas y básicamente dice
que haber contraído este virus puede
multiplicar hasta por 30 el riesgo de
sufrir esclerosis múltiple para hablar
de todo esto estamos con oscar francos
de nuevo bienvenido al programa él es
profesor de epidemiología y de salud
pública de la universidad de berna
doctor muy buenos días hay muchos
titulares que cuando salió este estudio
la semana pasada dijeron que se había
encontrado la causa de la esclerosis
múltiple no lo que provoca esta
enfermedad es precipitado decirlo de
esta manera
si se ha sacado un poco del contexto yo
creo que se ha exagerado no hemos
encontrado la causa de las cruces
múltiples para poner dentro del contexto
las claves es múltiple es una enfermedad
que afecta unos 3 millones de personas
en el mundo que tiene importantes
compromisos neurológicos y de calidad de
vida especialmente en la población
adulta joven es una enfermedad que no
tiene cura que una vez se diagnostica
dura toda la vida ha habido mejorías en
los tratamientos pero también es una
enfermedad que no es contagiosa no es
hereditaria es una enfermedad compleja
que es causada por múltiples factores y
yo creo que este estudio es excelente es
muy buen estudio ayuda a dar un paso más
para entender las causas de esta
enfermedad pero no se puede decir ahora
mismo que este virus causa esta
enfermedad ahora doctor los saludo muy
buen día como puede ser que un virus que
circula tan ampliamente por el mundo
provoque una enfermedad tan minoritaria
si es posible por hay varios mecanismos
que se han explicado uno de ellos es las
clases múltiple es una enfermedad
autoinmune entonces parece que el virus
al afectar las células nuestras defensas
nuestros defensas en el sistema inmune
entonces hace que crea una proteína de
este virus que se parece mucho a la
mielina que es lo que cubre los nervios
por así decirlo las células nerviosas es
como digamos que en un cable es como el
caucho o el plástico que cubre y aísla
el cable para que la conducción
eléctrica continúe entonces parece que
el organismo como que se equivoca
digámoslo así y ataca a esas esas
proteínas de la mielina de lo que cubre
ese cable y limita entonces la capacidad
de transmisión sin embargo como lo
acabas de decir es un virus que afecta
al 95% de la población y entonces como
pues no tiene sentido que por sí solo el
virus pueda causar la enfermedad sino es
posible que interactúe con otros
factores de ser genéticos o de medio
ambiente y esa interacción es lo que
tenemos que entender para ver si
realmente este virus juego o simplemente
una asociación aislada con esta
enfermedad
doctor algo que me parece bien
importante destacar es que la esclerosis
múltiple afecta de manera
desproporcionada a las mujeres como
cuatro veces más que a los hombres pero
este estudio se hizo con el ejército de
eeuu que es una muestra muy
masculinizada alrededor del 70% de las
personas de las que recibieron estos
datos eran hombres eso puede ser que
influya o que provoque errores en la
interpretación de los datos
es posible hemos visto nuevamente otro
ejemplo de cómo la mayoría de la
evidencia científica se conduce en
hombres en células masculinas en
animales masculinos y nos falta más
información en las mujeres y sabemos que
también uno de los factores que podría
interactuar para poder causar esta
enfermedad es el aspecto hormonal
entonces yo creo que aunque de estos
estudios son solamente este estudio en
particular es solamente en hombres
tenemos evidencia anteriormente también
en hombres y mujeres pero tenemos que
entender de manera separada hombres y
mujeres cuáles son los factores y cómo
interactúan en cada uno de estos de
estos grupos poblacionales para poder
generar posteriormente lo que es la
esclerosis múltiple pero si es necesario
tener más evidencias mujeres ahora
doctor le pregunto qué factores de
riesgo pueden estar en juego en esta
enfermedad de la esclerosis múltiple
se han descrito varios factores de
riesgo uno es este
es que llevamos varios años trabajando y
evaluando también el tabaquismo el fumar
cigarrillo entonces se ha ligado con se
ha asociado con esta enfermedad también
hay unos factores genéticos no un solo
gen sino unos una serie de genes o
problemas genéticos que podrían
contribuir a que esto ocurra también la
vitamina d se ha propuesto entonces hay
varios factores que parece que
interactúan entre ellos para generar
esta enfermedad que es tan compleja y
aún tenemos que clarificar cuáles son
esos factores cómo interactúan cuáles
son los mecanismos y poder entender
mejor qué es lo que está causando
realmente esta enfermedad
de acuerdo doctor pues muchas gracias
como siempre para por resolver todas
nuestras dudas alrededor de las últimas
noticias de salud aquí en france 24
así es doctor y marc gracias entonces
por hablar de salud por esta enfermedad
nosotros ahora vamos a darle espacio a
nuestra segunda mitad del día